cela fait à peine une journée que les
troupes américaines qui sont partis et
que les talibans ont pris le contrôle de
l'aéroport de kaboul nous avons pu me
promener dans les différents hangars les
différentes sections de l'aéroport et
c'est un vrai désastre le désordre est
partout tout est pratiquement détruits y
compris la partie civile de l'aéroport
les talibans et les autorités sont en
train de retirer tous les fils barbelés
toutes les ordures toutes les munitions
non percutée beaucoup et obus de
mortiers de grenades de cartouches nous
avons également pu voir tous les
véhicules militaires les hélicoptères
des avions à réaction abandonnés par les
états unis y compris à des hélicoptères
black hawk laissés sur place après
l'évacuation les etats-unis ont déclaré
que tous les avions avaient été sabotés
et nous pouvons en voir des signes
évidents mais fils par exemple ont été
coupées il y a plusieurs blocs
électriques qui manquent et beaucoup
d'équipements électroniques qui traînent
près du hangar
de toute évidence un marteau ou quelque
chose du genre a été utilisé
nous sommes également rendus au terminal
civile où nous avons constaté que tous
les ordinateurs ont été détruits les
caméras éteintes les lumières même les
tableaux de départ et d'arrivée ont été
renversées et détruit brisé
l'aéroport tel que nous le voyons
maintenant est hors service ce sera
impossible de le rouvrir pour des vols
civils dans un avenir immédiat mais
comme je l' ai déjà dit les armes que
nous avons vu la plupart des armes des
véhicules lourds comme ceux qui sont
derrière moi ont été sabotés est détruit
et
là nous voyons des cages pour chiens il
ya eu ali grande polémique en ligne sur
des chiens abandonnés par les militaires
américains bon oui les chiens ont été
abandonnées on ne les a pas évacué mais
ils n'ont pas été enfermés dans les
cages en l'état devant sont arrivés les
dernières troupes américaines les ont
libérés en quittant l'aéroport seuls des
cagettes alimentaires ont été laissées
ouvertes pour les animaux
quand les talibans sont arrivés ils ont
vu ces chiens qui couraient partout dans
l'aéroport mais il n'était pas agressif
il était apparemment désemparés
ce qui présente une version différente
des événements décrits par la presse
britannique qui insistait sur le fait
que les talibans les avait condamnés à
mort non ils nous disent qu'ils ont
attrapé certains chiens qu'ils vont
attraper les autres et les remettre au
service de l'armée ironie du sort les
chiens de l'armée américaine mais ça
veut désormais les talibans